los arcanos no son muy reactivos pero
pueden participar en reacciones de
combustión si hacemos reaccionar metano
con oxígeno obtenemos dióxido de carbono
y agua siempre en las reacciones de
combustión obtenemos co2 y h2o como
productos el delta h 0 para esta
reacción este menos 800 90 kilos por
cada molde metano eso significa que al
quemar un molde metano generamos 890
kilos de calor entonces esta es una
reacción exotérmica se libera calor el
calor o entalpía de combustión es el
calor liberado en la combustión completa
de un molde sustancia que en este caso
es el metano ahora veamos el hexano
dibujaré la estructura por aquí
tenemos 6 carbonos y observen que
tenemos estos grupos de h3 que
corresponden a estos y después tenemos 4
grupos
ch 2 1 2 3 y 4 4 tenemos cuatro grupos
ch 2 en el hexano y aquí tenemos el
calor de combustión que es el cambio
negativo de entalpía - delta h 0 kilo
jules por mol entonces para el hexano el
calor de combustión es de 4 mil 163
kilos por cada molde hexano quemado y
que pasa con el etano bueno aquí
aumentamos un grupo ch2 pasamos de 4 en
el hexano a cinco grupos de h2 en el
etano si tenemos 5 grupos
ch todos el calor de combustión aumenta
se libera más calor entonces si
aumentamos en
de carbonos aumenta el calor de
combustión ahora al aumentar un grupo ch
todos el calor de combustión cambia de
4.163 a 4.817 así que hay una diferencia
de 654 kilos jules y esto continúa
cuando pasamos al octano aquí tenemos
seis grupos de h2 y el calor de
combustión aumenta a cinco mil 471 y los
jules formol la diferencia también es de
654 kilos jules entonces si pasamos al
no nano que tiene siete grupos
ch todos podemos calcular el calor de
combustión simplemente agregando 654 a
cinco mil 471 entonces cinco mil 471 mil
es igual a 5 aquí tenemos 12 nos queda 1
esto da 11 y nos queda 6 6.125 el calor
de combustión es de 6 mil 125 kilos por
cada molde no nano el calor de
combustión es muy útil cuando queremos
comparar la estabilidad de los isómeros
por ejemplo aquí tenemos 3 isómeros que
son octanos 2 metil etanol y 22 de
metilhexanamina molecular de 8 h 18 y si
a cualquiera de estos lo hacemos
reaccionar con otros sabemos que los
productos serán co2 y h2o más h2o vamos
a balancear la reacción tenemos 8
carbonos del lado izquierdo así que
ponemos un 8 del lado derecho
pues tenemos 18 hidrógenos del lado
izquierdo y para tener 18 del lado
derecho simplemente ponemos un 9 porque
9 por todos es igual a 18 hidrógenos
ahora vamos con los oxígenos del lado
derecho tenemos 8 por 2 que es igual a
16 oxígenos más 9 oxígenos que tenemos
en el agua en total tenemos 25 oxígenos
del lado derecho así que necesitamos 25
oxígenos del lado izquierdo supongamos
que no tenemos este 2 así que solo
pondríamos 25 pero como si tenemos un 2
dividimos 25 entre 2 entonces de este
lado tenemos un molde de 8 h 18 y
necesitamos 25 entre dos moles de
oxígeno para completar la reacción ahora
que ya tenemos nuestra reacción
balanceada
necesitamos comparar los valores de
combustión del octano 2 metano y 22 y
metil ex zanon para saber cuál es más
estable aquí tenemos un diagrama de
energía de nuestros isómeros del lado
izquierdo tenemos la energía o calor
todos éstos isómeros pueden producir los
mismos productos 802 + 9 h2o y hay un
nivel de energía asociado con estos
productos
podemos decir que corresponde a este
pero analicemos el calor de combustión
para cada uno de los isómeros el octano
tiene un calor de combustión de 5 mil
471 kilos jules por mol entonces esta es
la energía del octano ahora vamos con el
2 metil hepta no
esta es la energía de nuestros productos
y la energía para el 2 metil eta no esté
aproximadamente 5 mil 466 kilos por mol
esa es la energía que se libera al
quemar dos metí lenta no y como la
energía de los productos es la misma
observen que tenemos un calor de
combustión más pequeño significa que el
nivel de energía para el 2 metil hepta
no es menor que para el octano
finalmente veamos el 22 dimetil hexano
este es el nivel de energía de nuestros
productos y el calor de combustión es de
5 mil 458 kilos por mol esa es la
energía que se libera al quemar un molde
2,2 dimetil hexano este es el calor de
combustión más pequeño la energía es
menor ahora comparemos la estabilidad de
los isómeros
a mayor energía menos estable es el
compuesto entonces como el octano tiene
el valor más alto de energía es el menos
estable
este es el menos estable de los 3
por otro lado a menor energía más
estable es un compuesto así que el 22
dimetil hexano es el y somero más
estable de los tres más estable
y ahora podemos pensar en tendencias
observen que cuando pasamos de octano a
2 metano y de ahí a 22 dimetil hexano
estamos aumentando las ramificaciones
aumenta la ramificación
y qué pasa con el calor de combustión
bueno si definimos el calor de
combustión como el cambio negativo de
entalpía el calor de combustión
disminuye de 5 mil 471 a 5 mil 466 a 5
mil 458 entonces disminuye el calor de
combustión y qué me dicen de la
estabilidad observen que la estabilidad
aumenta conforme aumentamos las
ramificaciones entonces si aumenta la
ramificación eso significa que aumenta
la estabilidad de un compuesto así que
es importante que sepan analizar los
calores de combustión a menor energía
más estable es el compuesto entonces el
compuesto que tiene la energía de
combustión más alta es el menos estable
y el compuesto con la energía de
combustión más baja es el más estable
así que los alcanos ramificados tienen
menor energía son más estables que los
arcanos lineales